what's happening beautiful people Uncle
Joey here to do ass the internet for my
boys over at bar stool okay you got to
read them to me I'm blind though
would you rather your girlfriend be able
to read your thoughts during sex or read
your thoughts all the other time except
for sex
so doing sex during sex yeah
you think that she would like what what
you're thinking about during sex oh yeah
I think about really [__] animalistic
type [__]
I'm thinking about what I want to do and
what I can do is two different [__]
situations so at least when I'm coming
after a minute she can look at my
thoughts and realize I want to do other
things now
you tried your best sorry about the
language
would you rather uh always come
prematurely or never come again
if I didn't come prematurely I would
never come
there's a lot of heart but
would you rather have to watch porn
upside down or Sports upside down for
the rest of your life
I'm not a big porn guy really yeah it's
disgusting
I'm not a big guy too it's disgusting
disgusting you I do you have you never
I've watched it when I was a kid I got
70s porn that'll knock you into that's
the most traumatized I ever was dude
that was it was like going to [__] in
the strip club uh the peep shows on 42nd
Street those crackles that come in like
well it is before crack they were glue
holes
like [__] at five in the morning what
was what was the porn you bought where
the the chicks Sabatino that was it the
the whipped cream or the American yeah
that was it it was like three movies
plus a projector
for 1995. so we all chipped in like four
bucks
six weeks delivery and handling you know
the whole thing but when you're a kid
you're used to that remember you wanted
to get you got beat up at the beach and
you ordered the Joe weida how to get
stronger yeah I ordered it just for the
trophy and [__]
just about that about that time and then
I have friends that always try to push
it on me I don't know I mean the uh the
the they put they make a whip a Miracle
Whip sandwich and they put it on the
guy's dick and then she just started to
eat it
so she was like looking around the room
and you hear director go and suck it
suck it look at it and she's like it was
[__] bad boy would you rather fight
Mike Tyson or sound like his voice for
the rest of your life sound like his
voice for the rest of my life dude they
still have those they have those videos
like you think like he said someone ages
obviously they get a little slower but
like Tyson can still move there was that
one that came out just the other day of
uh Holyfield no Foreman George Foreman
dude it was right that's muscle memory
it was I don't care how old but they can
only do it for a minute yeah
one [__] punch for me he wasn't
moving so fast but he's like kind of
like limbered up to the bag and he threw
[__] one and I was like that would
explode explode yeah uh would you bang
your cousin to win the Powerball
I don't have a cousin but if you did
I'll do anything to win the power
would you rather never get oral sex
again or you can only get oral sex the
rest of your life you could never [__]
normal again well when you're 20 you
want oral sex at my age my dick is old
and you really don't want nobody looking
at it so
if you're a real Christian
do that to people like this poor young
lady
sitting there dying inside
you had to get one movie quote tattooed
on your body what would it be
leave the gun take the cannolis yeah I
[__] knew you were gonna say that
that's a great line can you still go to
your Barber if your Barber is racist
yeah that's what am I gonna do yeah
like it might learn something new would
you rather wake up in the middle of the
night to see that a massive dude has
broken into your house or you see a
ghost
a ghost yeah yeah I would have thought
you would be like I can handle this guy
I can't handle ghosts
you can't handle a ghost yeah you don't
think a ghost can handle you [__] though
Little Ghost he's dead
that's what I mean you can't you can't
do anything we just yell racist slurs on
each other how's that until he [__]
goes back to hell what happened wherever
he can I dealt with goats
I'm a Santeria guy
all right last one this is perfect so
you guys have you you have your new book
out if you were reading the story of
your life and you got up to the present
day would you keep reading it knowing
that you can't change anything meaning
do you want to know where your life ends
up or would you rather just
no I don't want to know where it is
though nah [__] it let's stop right here
and let's let the listen the best thing
in life is that you don't know when
you're gonna punch the ticket
you know yeah you turn the page there's
only one page left in the book yeah
that's it
that's it man
I'm happy I got that bagel
[Laughter]
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out